the flames turned blue and I heard a
voice and ever since that day I have
hated magic and all those who practice
hey youtubers it's Charlie welcome to my
game of Thrones Season 4 preview for
varies if you see my other Game of
Thrones videos recently then you know
we're taking our favorite characters and
talking about what they're going to be
doing in season 4 as always spoilers for
everything from seasons 123 and mild
spoilers for everything in books four
and five but feel like Game of Thrones
really buries the lead a lot but varies
is the spider of King's Landing remember
influence grows like a weed and he tends
his garden better than anyone else
that's right he really goes out of his
way to appear as non-threatening as
possible just like maester pycelle only
he's obviously not an 80 year old man
but he's definitely playing the long con
so let's talk about what various true
goal is what his motivations are and
what he's going to be doing in season 4
number one what's he doing he is trying
to restore the Targaryen line to the
throne namely that being Danny right now
because there aren't that many Targaryen
xand Westeros or the eastern lands how
do we know this well we saw him plotting
with Illyrio in the basement and Illyrio
has been hiding the Targaryen since
Robert's rebellion why does he want to
restore the Targaryen well he is very
well-read and he understands the dangers
of the White Walkers the great other and
what they're going to do if they happen
to take over Westeros when he says he
serves the realm he's talking about a
united Seven Kingdoms and right now
they're very much at war the war of the
five kings is really putting a dent in
that plan so what he's trying to do is
bring someone back into power who he
feels can unite all the kingdoms and
since he's trying to restore Targaryen
obviously Danny's at the top of that
list but there are several other
bastards at the top of that list who
could be contenders for that spot
including Gendry and a boy named snow
too what is he doing in season 4 well
he's trying to eliminate some of the
kinks in his plan to put that person
back on the throne but since he's the
spider of Westeros you're never going to
see him crossbow anyone to death or stab
someone in the heart so varies prefers
to act through other agents and he's a
master of creating circumstances by
which events just unfold on their own
and that's what's going to happen in
season 4 he's going to help do what he
can to create the circumstances to get
some of these people who are in the way
between this Targaryen restoration more
to that george RR martin recently did an
interview where he talked about the
purple wedding and for those of you that
hadn't read the books i won't spoil it
too much but let's just say it gets very
grisly it's like this season's red
wedding that's right it's an event of
the first order
so it's going to be amazing to watch on
screen but various doesn't take a direct
role in this event he really just kind
of sits around and allows it to happen
he's also very integral to the events
after the purple wedding killing two
birds with one stone as it were well
it's not exactly a stone but you get the
idea number three why is he doing all
this what does he believe in he's not
really tied to any of the bloodlines in
Westeros obviously he's really up on the
Targaryen right now but that's only
because he thinks they're the best for
the job if you remember that speech he
gave with Tyrion it's in the picture
right here where he pulls the wizard out
of that box he basically hates magic
users magic and all those who practice
it mostly because of that experience
when he got cut and he saw the demon in
the fire or at least heard the demon in
the fire so he understands the threat
that the White Walkers and supernatural
beings represent to Westeros for those
of you that aren't up on the back story
originally variously kind of intended
for Rhaegar to take the throne because
he felt like he was actually a true king
unlike his father Mad King Aerys but
Robert's rebellion happened and that
really threw a wrench in his plans so
next up is Danny but let's talk about
other contenders to that throne in the
context of what the showrunners are
doing with it remember they're changing
George RR Martin's story just a little
bit to fit the TV show so they're
condensing a lot of characters into one
so i think that there's going to be a
couple characters from books four and
five they're going to get rid of and
they're just going to use characters
they already have on the show right now
namely Gendry being one of those and Jon
Snow so I think they're going to change
things just a little bit to kind of
bring them more to the forefront so
earlier when I mentioned other
contenders for that throne I think that
there are certain characters in book
five the mummer's dragon for people who
have read the books that I think might
get folded into gondry's character they
already did that with eadric storm for
Gendry but I think they're just going to
continue to do that more so it's
entirely possible that you could have a
faction develop around Gendry trying to
put him on the throne to not necessarily
various but another group in Westeros
but let me know what you think what is
very going to do in season 4 to kind of
get rid of some of the threats to his
Targaryen restoration what is he going
to do with Mad King Joffrey obviously
that's a big hurdle to get over and is
he going to do something about
Littlefinger they have quite a rivalry
right now obviously them going against
each other would be a major major battle
anyway since so many of you requested it
my next game of thrones preview will be
for Queen Cersei it's going to be
amazing be sure to subscribe to get it
i'll try and post that on monday and
thank you so much you guys I just
officially hit
five thousand subscribers on my channel
I posted a Sherlock winters video I've
already deemed all the winners on my
channel I'll be doing another giveaway
for the doctor who 50th anniversary too
in the meantime you can click here to
check out out my other previews for Game
of Thrones Season 4 and you can click
here to check out all my videos for
legend of korra season 2 thank you so
much for watching you guys are amazing
high fives see you tomorrow
you